costs are continuing to climb as
inflation takes hold all across the
country that of course cuts into summer
travel budgets so families might look at
a staycation instead and las vegas is
listed as a top spot sasha lofta spoke
with an economic expert about why this
trend also good for our local economy
sasha
denise and brian it is really lucky that
we have the las vegas strip available to
us anytime now a local economist i spoke
with tonight said it's a really good
time to take advantage of all our city
has to offer as those costs continue to
climb
we all know las vegas is the
entertainment capital of the world
but for many of us it's also home and
with costs on the rise it's a good time
to take advantage of all our city has to
offer staying at home is probably
pretty good inflation is still raging
and gas prices continue to climb so many
are opting for staycations vacations
staycations like hey i don't know if
you'd really have to leave here a recent
wallet hub study ranked las vegas as the
sixth best city in the country for
locals to enjoy some good old rest and
relaxation
with nightlife and hiking options listed
as top factors we can do it for much
cheaper by just staying here local
certified financial planner mahesh
odrani says staying home for a vacation
doesn't just cut travel costs and give
your wallet a break it also gives our
local economy a boost by spending the
money by staying locally we're able to
keep the money in our local economy
that's the beauty of being in vegas it's
a great place as entertainment capital
of the world so if you're planning your
next summer getaway but want to save a
few bucks consider taking a trip here to
our very own beautiful backyard it's
there if you want it
now in terms of the factors that
wallethub considered for that survey
nightlight nightlife options rather were
ranked at the top and cost of
restaurants were ranked at the bottom in
regards to staycations and we have a
full look at that report on our website
eight newsnow dot com reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now